the film is fantastic my question is in
terms of the tone the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is heathered matching the
comics have gained more fantastic more
out there I wonder if the humor was a
part a way of trying to ground some of
that to make it palatable and in the
other sense as the actors of the cast as
the world is getting more fantastical
and things are being a more strange how
what did you find to hook yourself as
actors into grounding your performances
and again well it's interesting talking
about the humor of them I saw it last
week and was really surprised at the
amount of humor because I'm such a
miserable bust my character was
completely grounded in vengeance he was
like a maniac for revenge the idea I
think with Alan and Kevin was to to
suggest that the the the Dark Elves were
as ancient a race as the Asgardians and
had a history which is why we gave them
a language and had a culture but most of
all they had a grudge which they had
slept on for millions of years what's
interesting about the film is it does
have a variety of tones and myself and a
Diwali who fortune is not here played
Algrim and curse our job was to bring
the threat and the Menace and the
jeopardy so we we grounded in bitterness
well you said earlier that you had to
get up it's 3:00 a.m. to put your
costume on and you were so bitter and
angry about time that was over my makeup
core was about three o'clock I was in
the chair about four o'clock ten o'clock
a at the set so I was not a happy elf
Chris did actually touch on this a
little bit earlier but I'm interesting
cuz what you know we people say conflict
is Jar america--the is the antagonist
here but we keep talking still about the
brothers and the romantic Dino was
really did I meant in America
well what it mean what was the point of
that story
what is the repeating myself it's
vengeance he is a maniac
for vengeance there were some scenes
which for understandable reasons didn't
make the final Court which explained a
bit of a backstory between me my
ancestors and all who is Odin's father
but basically the Dark Elves
before the big band before the big band
centuries and centuries ago were
humiliated in defeat and ground into the
dirt by Odin and Malik Eve has slept on
that and the theme of that the theme of
that element is his vengeance really as
we know as somebody wants somebody said
you know let he who seeks vengeance be
careful to dig two graves because it's a
pointless exercise but that's it my job
was to bring a dark element that the
dark world but the Dark Elves are
seeking to turn light into darkness it's
really that simple and that classic if
you like and we needed that in a movie
where our our villain from from Avengers
we want to play in a slightly more
ambiguous way in order to do that we
needed somebody who could drive the
entire storyline and give for a reason
to to have something to fight against
and we're all jumping on this one I mean
Malekith is a purist he's a
fundamentalist he's a zealot one of the
major themes in the movie for me is
something that most of our care should
have to confront in one way or another
and it was a quest it was a it was a
theme that was expressed very clearly by
Malekith in the scene that you will find
on your blu-ray
where he's confronting Odin Denise he
says you have to ask yourself as I once
did what are you willing to sacrifice
for what you believe and every character
goes to a turning point like that in the
movie and Malekith is the kind of guy
who would sacrifice anything for
principle and we've seen him do it and
forward learns the difficult version of
that and decides to go a different way
you